I wonder if this picture is really
okay.It's March if I'm
fast.I've escaped from pirates many times.
It
doesn't look like there's a Shinogi on board, and I can't
find any other ships that seem to move.
moroso,
tell me to pay for this flower
, but you're still bald.
You said you were going to bring a new subordinate, but it
seems like you're here. [Applause] It's been a while.
These guys are really good at
it, and they know things
behind the scenes that we don't even know,
so it's too dangerous.
No
, you've been given permission to move on the condition that you join the squad I'm
leading.
kn
I got it quickly I
think I'll have to accept it [music] I guess I'll have to accept it [music] It's
black yeah yeah
yeah
[music]
I don't know what happens
Please understand  happy
me
[music]